So, this is what I've come up with.
I have the modal's HTML, inside the body of our page.
It has its own unique id, which in this case is project1.
It's got its own label, which is Favorite App Page.
And then inside modal-body, we have some custom content, including an image and
a big block of text.
At the very bottom, we've got a button here that will close our modal.
Scrolling up.
We see that for the image, for the same Favorite App project,
we've got a new attribute called data-toggle and it's equal to modal.
And the target is of course project1.
Put it all together and we get to come to our page.
Click on the kitty and get a better description.